so
one of the criticisms now is because you
forget the
the lessons of 20th century history and
the atrocities committed under communism
that
you may be a little bit more willing to
uh accept some of those ideologies into
our
the united states society that this kind
of um
that forgetting that capitalistic forces
are part of
the reason why we have what we have
today
there's a fear amongst some now that we
would
have would allow basically communism
to take hold in america i mean
jordan and others speak to this kind of
idea i tend to
not be so fearful of it i think it's
on the surface it's not deep within
i do see the world as very complicated
as a
as they're needing to be a role of
having support for each other
on certain political levels economic
levels and then also supporting
entrepreneurs
it's like um
that the kind of enforcing of outcomes
that is fundamental to the communist
system
is not something we're actually close to
and some of that is just fear-mongering
for
for uh for likes on twitter kind of
thing
if i could come in on that because i
agree with you 100 i've spent a lot of
time
writing and looking at this and talking
to people about this um
there's no communism in the united
states there never has been
and there certainly isn't now and and
i'll say this both from an academic
point of view but also from just
spending a lot of time observing young
people in the united states
even those on the farthest left take
whoever you think is the farthest left
they don't even understand what
communism is they're not communist in
any sense
americans are raised in a vernacular and
environment of private property
ownership
and as you know better than anyone if
you believe in private property you
don't believe in communism so
the what what the sort of bernie sanders
kind of socialist
elements that's very different right and
i would say
some of that not all of that some of
that does harken back
to actually what won in the cold war
there were many social democratic
elements of what the united states did
that led to our winning the cold war
for example the new deal uh
was invest in government money in
propping up business in propping up
labor unions
and during the cold war we spent more
money than we had ever spent in our
history
on infrastructure on schools
on providing social support social
security
our national pension system being one of
them
so you could argue actually that social
democracy
is very compatible with capitalism and i
think that's the debate we're having
today how much social democracy i also
say
that the capitalism we've experienced
the last 20 years is different from the
capitalism of the cold war
uh during the cold war there was the
presumption in the united states
that you had to
pay taxes to support our cold war
activities
that it was okay to make money but the
more money you made the more taxes you
had to pay
um we had the highest marginal tax rates
in our history during the cold war
now the aversion to taxes and of course
no one ever likes paying taxes but the
notion that we can do things on deficit
spending that's a
post-cold war phenomenon that's not a
cold war phenomenon so
so much of the capitalism that we're
talking about today is not the
capitalism of the cold war and maybe
again we can learn that and see that see
how we can
reform capitalism today and and and get
rid of this
false worry about communism in the
united states yeah you know you make me
actually realize something important
what we have to remember is the words we
use on the surface about different
policies what you think is right and
wrong
is actually different than the core
thing that like is in your blood
the core ideas that are there
of i i do see the united states as this
there there's this fire that burns of
individual freedoms
of uh of
of property rights these these basic
foundational ideas that
everybody just kind of takes for granted
and i think if you
hold on to them if you're like
raised in them talking about
ideas of social security of universal
basic income of of of reallocation of
resources
is a fundamentally different kind of
discussion than you had in the soviet
union
i think the value of the individual is
so core to the american system that you
basically cannot
possibly do the kind of atrocities
that you saw in the in the soviet union
but
of course you never know the slippery
slope has a way of
changing uh changing things but i do
believe the things you're born with
it's just so core to this country it's
it's part of the
i don't know what your thoughts are we
are in texas i'm
not necessarily i don't necessarily want
to have a gun control type of
conversation but
the reason i really like guns
it doesn't make any sense but
philosophically
it's it's such a declaration of
individual rights
that's so different than the
conversations i hear with my russian
family and my russian friends
that the gun is very possible that
having guns is bad for society
in the sense that like it'll lead to
more violence but there's something
about this discussion
um it that
like that proclaims the value of my
freedom as an individual i'm not being
eloquent in it but there's very few
debates where whenever people are saying
should
you have what level of gun control all
those kinds of things
what i hear is it's a fight for
how much freedom even if it's stupid
freedom
should the individual have i think
that's i think that's what that's what's
articulated quite often i i think uh
combining your two points which are
great points i think there is something
about american individualism which is
deeply ingrained uh in our culture in
our society and it means that
the kinds of bad things that happen are
different usually not as bad but
but our individualism often covers up
for um
vigilante activity and individual
violence toward people that you wouldn't
have in a more collective culture
so in the soviet union it was at a much
worse scale and it was done by
by government organizations in the
united states it's you know individuals
the history of lynching in our country
for example
uh sometimes it's individual police
officers sometimes it's others
again the vast majority police officers
are good people don't do harm to people
but there are
these examples and they they are able to
fester in our society because of our
individualism now
gun ownership is about personal freedom
i think for a lot of people
and um there's no doubt that in our
history
included in the second amendment which
can be interpreted in different ways
is the presumption that people should
have the right to defend themselves
which is what i think you're getting at
here
that you should not be completely
dependent for your defense
on an entity that might not be there for
you you should be able to defend
yourself and guns symbolize that um
i think that's a fair point but i think
it's also a fair point to say
that as with everything uh defining what
self-defense is is really important so
does self-defense mean i can have a
bazooka
does it mean i can have weapons that are
designed for a military battlefield
to mass kill people that seems to me to
be very different
from saying i should have a handgun or
some small arm
to defend myself uh that distinction
alone would make a huge difference
most of the uh mass shootings at least
which are a proportion smaller
proportion of the larger gun deaths in
the united states which are larger than
any other society but at least the mass
shootings
are usually perpetrated by people who
have not self-defense weapons
but mass killing mass killing weapons
and i think i think there's an important
distinction there
the constitution talks about a right to
bear arms for a well-regulated militia
when the framers talked about arms
that did not mean the ability to kill as
many people as you want to kill
it meant the ability to defend yourself
so let's have that conversation i think
it would be useful as a society
stop talking about guns or no guns what
is it that we as citizens need
to feel we can defend ourselves yes yeah
i mean guns
have this complicated issue that it can
cause harm to others i tend to
see sort of maybe indra like
legalization of drugs
i tend to believe that we should have
the freedom to do stupid things
yeah as long as we're not harming lots
of other people yes
and then guns of course have the
property that they can be used
it's not just you know a bazooka i would
argue is pretty stupid
to own for your own self-defense but it
has the very
negative side effect of being
potentially used to harm other people
right and you have to you have to
consider that kind of stuff by the way
as a side note to the listeners uh
there's been a bunch of people
saying that uh lex is way too
libertarian for my
tastes no i actually am just
struggling with ideas and sometimes put
on different hats in these conversations
i
i um think through different ideas
whether they're left right or
libertarian
that's true for gun control that's true
for immigration it's true for all that
i think we should we should have
discussions in the space of ideas
versus in the space of bins we put each
other in labels and we'll put each other
100 and also change our minds all the
time
try out say say stupid stuff with the
best of intention
trying our best to think through it and
then
after saying it think about it for a few
days and then change your mind and grow
in this way
you